[Musique]
de remagen à l'herbe
les derniers jours de la guerre en
europe
au début du mois de mars 1945 hitler
exigea que tous les ponts sur le rhin
soit détruit afin que les troupes
alliées ne puisse traverser le large
fleuve
pourtant la 9e division blindée us
s'empara du pont ferroviaire de l'oudon
undof encore intacte au soir du 7 mars
bien que les allemands aient tenté de le
détruire
les charges n'avaient pas explosé les
soldats américains profitèrent de cette
situation et quelques heures après le
général hodges faisait traverser ses
troupes
le führer ivre de rage que ses ordres
n'ait pas été suivie ordonna que les
officiers responsables de cet échec soit
fusillés
il demanda à goering de mobiliser tout
le potentiel de la luftwaffe pour
détruire ce pont au plus vite
goering donna à la destruction du pont
la priorité absolue exhortant même des
pilotes volontaires à se jeter sur lui
avec leurs avions
la luftwaffe effectué à de nombreuses
missions sans succès en raison du manque
de visibilité
les canons anti aériens américains
durent faire face à une grande diversité
d'appareils ennemis du chasseur
bombardier monomoteur tels que le focke
wulf 190 jusqu'aux appareils les plus
avancés de l'arsenal allemand
réaction messerschmidt 262 armés de
bombes et des jets de bombardements
arado 234 tentèrent également de mettre
le point en morceaux
dans les 24 heures qui suivirent sa
prise les forces de hodges créer une
tête de con forte de plus de 8000 hommes
soutenue par les blindés des 9e et 18e
bataillon d'infanterie
mais les ordres avaient limité l'avant
ses alliés à seulement une dizaine de
kilomètres au delà du pont vers
l'autoroute cologne francfort
dix jours après le pont gooden dorff
s'écroula dans le rhin
il était de toute façon trop tard pour
la résistance allemande car les
américains avaient établi une solide
tête de pont et installer un pont plus
haut afin d'améliorer les
approvisionnements des troupes de
l'autre côté du fleuve
les opportunités offertes par ce pont
avait donné lieu à une controverse au
sein du haut commandement allié
son exploitation fut réduite au profit
de l'offensive massive sur le rhin prévu
pour la fin du mois de mars sous le
commandement de montgomery
le 23 mars le 21e groupe d'armées de
montgomery traverse alors hein
eisenhower orientale essentiel de la
tacc alliés des plaines du nord ouest
vers le centre de l'allemagne
sachant que berlin avait toutes les
chances d'être pris par les soviétiques
eisenhower pensait que les objectifs
militaires les plus intéressants se
trouvaient dans le centre de l'allemagne
l'offensive de l' us army et de
montgomery fut réduite à nettoyer
l'allemagne du nord à la lgv après avoir
attendu que montgomerie traverse le rhin
hodges et sa première arme et quittèrent
leur tête de pont de remagen le 25 mars
et avançaient rapidement vers l'est en
direction de marc bouré d'essen la
résistance allemande étant assez faible
kesselring en tant que commandant des
forces de l'ouest disposait pourtant sur
le papier de 60 division mais la plupart
était très affaibli et leur moral au
plus bas la résistance fut désordonnée
et seuls quelques groupes improvisé
tentèrent de ralentir l'offensive
américaine
elle fut vite repoussés après avoir
détaché la 9e armée du commandement de
montgomery et l'avoir placée sous
l'autorité de bradley le général simpson
reçu l'ordre d'abandonner sa tête de
pont du nord de la route le 27 mars et
le filet vers l'est vers minster en
s'emparant de la ville de bochum sur le
chemin la neuvième de simpson est la
première de ashes étaient les pinces
nord et sud de la structure en tenaille
du général bradley pour encercler
l'armée allemande b dans la ruhr
[Musique]
l'avancée américaine fut si rapide et
l'opposition allemande si inefficace que
les chars de pointe des deux armées us
entrèrent en contact à l'ipp stats juste
avant l'aube du 1er avril
fermant ainsi une poche ou le septième
corps allemand et 19 division était
coincé
de nombreuses villes et villages sur
leurs routes se rendirent
police locale et autorités furent
prompte à offrir leur assistance aux
troupes américaines pour éviter au
village et aux villes d'être détruite
nombreux soldats allemands se rendirent
ces prisonniers donnait la mesure de la
gravité de la situation de l'allemagne
en 1945
car la file de prisonniers comprenait
des garçons de 14 ans et des
quinquagénaires
le général patton et sa troisième armée
partir du rhin vers francfort puis avec
le douzième corps avant ça rapidement
vers le nord-est le main fut franchie
sur un ponton flottant et le 28 mars des
éléments de la quatrième division
comment certes a traversé en direction
de hanovre rejoints ensuite par la
première armée à essen
le plan d'eisenhower commandait aux
premières 3e et 9e armée de foncer vers
l'est
avant même que la poche de la ruhr ne
soit réduite afin de prendre les villes
de l'actif et dresde
cette manoeuvre pouvait non seulement
coupés l'allemagne en deux mais aussi
permettre l'occupation de la dernière
région industrielle encore aux mains du
troisième reich la 7e armée de patcher
c'est la première armée française devait
avancer vers le sud de l'allemagne
depuis le main mais les rumeurs de
poches de résistance dans les alpes
allait plus tard modifier ce plan
lorsque les troupes allemandes qui se
trouvait dans la poche de la ruhr l'âge
de plus de 150 kilomètres se rendirent
les américains furent surpris de la
quantité de matériel récupéré et du
nombre effarant de soldats capturés
pas moins de trois cent dix sept mille
hommes un chiffre plus important que
celui atteint lors de la chute de la
tunisie ou de stalingrad
les combats s'arrêtèrent lorsque les
allemands eurent réalisé que leur
résistance ne retarderait un rien
l'avancé américaine en allemagne walter
modèle savait que la reddition n'était
pas une sortie honorable pour lui et son
armée
afin de ne pas causer de souffrances
inutiles à ses hommes sachant que la
guerre était désormais perdu il pris la
décision de dissoudre son commandement
libérant ses troupes de l'autorité
militaire
[Musique]
de ce fait des milliers d'entre eux se
rendirent chaque jour aux américains
militaires américains à wuppertal qui a
assumé la responsabilité de 68
prisonniers à son arrivée au centre de
détention se retrouver avec un total de
bien que le général mathieu ridgway et
tenter de s'assurer de la reddition du
commandant album
[Musique]
ce dernier qui avait vu le sort réservé
à ceux qui s'étaient rendus à stalingrad
ne voulant pas subir une telle honte
s'enfonça dans une forêt près de 12 the
berg et se suicida le 21 avril
[Musique]
un capable d'abriter correctement un tel
nombre de prisonniers
les américains se contentèrent de les
placer provisoirement dans des champs
entouré de barbelés
[Musique]
certains soldats parmi les plus âgées
vivaient là la deuxième défaite de leur
pays
au sein des armées alliées se trouvaient
des troupes chargées de faire régner
l'ordre dans la population civile
allemande afin de restaurer un semblant
de vie dans ce qui restait levin
l'occupation par les forces alliées
marqué pour la population de la ruhr la
fin de cinq ans de bombardements
intensifs par les bombardiers américains
et anglais qui avaient réduit la
principale région industrielle moteur de
la machine de guerre allemande un vaste
champ de ruines
circulant à travers les rues des cités
dévastée par les combats
une file sans fin de véhicules et de
porte char transportait les
approvisionnements et l'équipement dont
les troupes de première ligne avait
besoin pour progresser rapidement
munitions essence huile étaient
nécessaires en grande quantité
constituant le nerf de la guerre moderne
mais aussi un défi logistique sans
lequel aucune armée ne peut combattre
efficacement sur ces images parmi les
nombreux types de véhicules on distingue
les célèbres jeep les camions de
transport stoudemire et gmc 6,6 des
véhicules de reconnaissance d'objets 214
dm 26 dragonwave jeunes et un porte-char
lourdes highmount et transportant am4
sherman au même moment
l'us air force continuer d'envoyer ses
chasseurs au dessus des zones
d'opération ils ne rencontraient qu'une
faible opposition de la luftwaffe c p 51
mustang du 354e fighter squadron sont
ici en patrouille au-dessus de
l'allemagne
l'avion au premier plan pourtant un as
de pique et piloté par le
lieutenant-colonel gordon g
un nas crédité de 7 victoires aériennes
et 9 victoires au sol
ce squadron faisait partie du 355e
fighter groupe
le troisième groupe le plus titré de
toute la huitième air force
même à ce stade de la guerre quelques
missions étaient exceptionnellement
rempli par les chasseurs allemands ayant
survécu saisie sur ce film de signer
mitrailleuse infos que vous le feu 190
des neuf est pris en chasse et détruit
par un p-51 dans de telles conditions de
supériorité aérienne vraiment peu de
pilotes de chasseurs à élise de la
luftwaffe survivaient un m18l cat
un chasseur de chars rapide émergent de
la fumée suivi par un certain nombre de
m3 half track chargé d'infanterie
alors que l'as vence américaine en
allemagne centrale s'accélère la
première armée de hodges avait reçu le
rôle principal dans cette opération
le 4 avril ils avaient été rejoints par
des unités de la troisième armée qui
était remontée du sud pour le retrouver
à cassone les ordres de patton était de
prolonger cette avancée vers l'est mais
aussi vers le sud ou hodges pouvait
progresser vers erfurt et weimar afin de
libérer la ville industrielle de
chemnitz au nord des lignes de hodges
la première armée de simpson pousser en
direction de la forêt de tonnes burger
dans laquelle les allemands tentaient
d'organiser une dernière ligne de
défense le long des routes suivies par
les trois heures mais les soldats
trouver les villages ouvert marquée par
des drapeaux blancs des groupes de
soldats allemands dont la plupart
avaient abandonné leurs armes avancer
vers l'ouest afin de se rendre
pour les chefs des chats roulant à
tombeau ouvert sur ces terrains plats il
n'était pas question de s'arrêter mais
de les diriger vers l'arrière où tout
était prêt pour les recevoir
je
sous le nom de code de mission et bras
vingt nouveaux charte et 26 pershing
furent envoyés en toute hâte en europe
en 1945 en vue d'expérimentation au
combat
ce chars lourds avaient été conçus en
urgence car le char sherman s'étaient
retrouvés dominé par les tigres allemand
même quand ils étaient équipés du canon
de 76 mm allons pu monter sur les
nouvelles tours elle comme ici ces trois
modèles de fin de production
le chairman était toujours incapable de
percer le blindage frontale des tigres
le sherman dispose lui d'un blindage
avant improvisée afin d'offrir une
protection un peu plus efficace
mais en dépit de ses limites le sherman
n'en fut pas moins une machine de guerre
redoutable
en effet il ne pouvait égaler le panzer
4 et le tigre en termes de puissance de
feu ou de blindage mais il était plus
fiable et plus rapide
le manque de puissance de feu initiale
fut un désavantage qu'un la doctrine
d'emploi des tanks de l'ua serbie
n'avait jamais envisagé que le sherman
puissent être engagées pour combattre
d'autres chars cette mission aurait dû
être laissée à des formations de
chasseurs de chars spécialisés équipés
du m10 disposant d'un canon de 76 mm et
plus tard du n 36 équipé d'un canon de
90 mm le rôle du sherman était celui
d'une force mobile de soutien à
l'infanterie opérant comme appui feu
afin de détruire les points forts et
demi c'est le rôle qu'il tient dans
cette séquence filmée comme l'avait
programmé pour lui us army
lors de son entrée en service en 1942 le
sherman valait n'importe quel autre char
moyens dans le monde
son évolution constante et son
amélioration
aller de pair avec l'incroyable
production qui totalisera plus de 40000
exemplaires à la fin de la guerre
cette production bien plus importante
que celle des chars allemands durant
tout le conflit en fit une arme efficace
du début à la fin de la guerre
le châssis du n 4 s'est également
révélée tout à fait polyvalent il servi
entre autres de base à des variantes
ultérieure comme le canon automoteur m7
prix est utilisé en soutien des
formations de blindés toutes les unités
de temps que moyens employés
le chaman principalement dans ses
versions ème 4 ème 4 à 1 et n 4 à 3
la plupart des m 4 à 2 et n 4 à 4 furent
livrés aux britanniques ainsi qu'aux
soviétique en application de la loi
prevail même si les allemands surnommait
de sherman le briquet ronson il fut
l'une des armes principales utilisé par
les américains pour venir à bout de la
wehrmacht
pourtant si souvent glorifier considéré
comme le principal chasseur bombardier
au début de la campagne européenne le
république b 47 thunderbolt fut
intensivement utilisée pour appuyer
l'avancée des forces américaines au sol
armé de 8 mitrailleuses 12 7 mm est
capable d'emporter de nombreuses bombes
et roquettes
le thunderbolt ainsi que le typhon
britannique que les allemands surnommait
jabour pour chasseurs bombardiers
multiplier à leur intervention
[Musique]
cp 47 au décollage sont des razer bac
mobilisables à volonté pour épauler les
troupes au sol l'épée 47 opérait depuis
des bases avancées proche du front mais
étaient engagés pour des missions de
mitraillages à l'intérieur des lignes
ennemies
il attaquait tout ce qu'ils trouvaient
le long des routes et des voies ferrées
[Musique]
ce groupe de b 47 des plus récents et
identifiables grâce à leur derrière bull
qui contraste avec ce film est un peu
plus tôt sont en train d'effectuer une
mission d'appui
en l'absence d'opposition de la
luftwaffe ces missions peuvent être
exécutés à la demande les tirs
observable ici met en action les huit
mitrailleuses et semble extrêmement
destructif
[Musique]
l'emploi de cette puissance aérienne
tactique allait littéralement paralysé
toutes les colonnes d'approvisionnement
circulent en deux jours
[Musique]
le fleuve fraser était un obstacle
majeur dans la progression des trois
armées alliées
il fut traversée par la neuvième art
mais le 5 avril
un véhicule blindé m us gorée un
précèdent un mk chairman bulldozer sur
le pont flottant construit pour le
traverser
suivi par deux récents m24 shafi chars
légers de reconnaissance
conçu pour remplacer le char léger m5
devenu obsolète
le m 24 très réussie fut encore très
utilisé bien après la guerre
la résistance des allemands donné
sporadiques
un groupe du cependant affronté des
soldats des fox tourner et des jeunesses
hitlériennes prêts à combattre jusqu'à
la mort ils tentèrent de ralentir les
troupes américaines en les harcelant
dans une petite ville qu'ils avaient
préparés pour leur défense
ici les premiers soldats faits
prisonniers cours les mains en l'air
vers l'arrière de la colonne
les m4 fonce à toute allure
les chamans continuent à tirer sur les
positions qui se retrouve rapidement
couvertes par un nuage de fumée due aux
explosions d'obus
puis l'infanterie avance des joints les
obstacles antichar improvisé constitué
de troncs d'arbres et de poteaux
télégraphiques soutenu par des poutres
métalliques une des armes allemandes les
plus redoutés était le lance-roquettes
anti-char panzerfaust 1m 4 à 3 vient
juste d'être touché par une de ses armes
doté d'une charge creuse les autres
sherman passe devant la carcasse brûlée
sans doute avec une pensée pour
l'équipage qui est probablement mort
dans son blindé le panzer faust peut
percer le blindage de n'importe quel
char alliés sans aucune difficulté
c'est sherman sur appliqué dans d'autres
combats
un modèle tardif m quatre a318 plus
connu sous le nom de easy eight utilise
ici sa mitrailleuse de tourelles pour
faire cesser les tirs ennemis
l'équipage d'un m16 priest utilisant un
obusiers de 105 mm assure ainsi un bon
soutien d'artillerie
le grand nombre d'obus tirés par ces
soldats démontre l'importance des
réapprovisionnements rapide depuis
l'arrière
après les tirs initiaux les troupes us
entre temps ville profitant de l'
avantage de la couverture offerte par
les chars les gm sain le fait que les
soldats et majoritairement leur arme à
l'épaule et marchent tranquillement dans
les rues laisse penser que la résistance
et demi a été balayé les destructions
alentours sont difficilement imputables
aux combats terrestres et tout porte à
croire que cette ville a été bombardée
par les avions alliés
l'un luftwaffe étant pratiquement
absente du ciel les approvisionnements
des unités les plus rapides devenait
possible par r le principal avions de
transport alliés durant tout le conflit
du pacifique au théâtre européen fut le
remarquable douglas c 47 dakota bien que
les derniers parachutage massif et eu
lieu lors de la traversée du rhin par le
21e groupe d'armées en mars des
parachutages plus légères esther
fréquent des parachutistes sautent est
depuis l'avion et les conteneurs de
matériel transportés sous le fuselage du
ses 47 étaient largués par l'équipage
le 11 avril des troupes de la 9ème art
mais à tenir l'elbe à magdebourg à
faible distance de berlin
cependant eisenhower s'était prononcé
contre la prise de la ville au sud de la
première armée avait atteint également
l'elbe le 24 avril après de durs combats
la troisième armée traverse ilife psych
pour atteindre called it qui fut prise
par la 69e division d'infanterie de l'us
army
la plus grande partie de la psyché était
en ruines à la suite des bombardements
intensifs subi pendant trois ans cette
ville avait en effet une importance
capitale dans la production industrielle
militaire
ce dirigeant de l'est vers l'ouest de
l'allemagne des hordes de réfugiés après
tentait d'échapper à l'avancée de
l'armée rouge qui était elle même en
train d'atteindre l'elbe
des soldats américains inspectent ici
des soldats allemands et examine leur
carte d'identité
au grand nombre de prisonniers capturés
à l'ouest du fleuve s'ajoutaient les
hommes des unités de l'est cherchant à
éviter la captivité chez les soviétiques
cette multitude de prisonniers de guerre
allemands posait de sérieux problèmes à
l' us army
des plans à plus long terme allait
s'imposer pour assurer leur hébergement
et filtrer ces centaines de milliers de
soldats de la wehrmacht
d'innombrables travailleurs venus de
france et des pays bas ainsi que des
centaines de prisonniers alliés certains
détenus depuis la campagne de france en
1940 manifestent leur joie immense
d'avoir été libéré par les troupes
américaines
au même moment l'armée de patton
atteignait colditz
le drapeau tricolore est en tête alors
que les ex prisonniers marche
joyeusement dans les rues de la guiche
cette scène s'est répétée dans toute
l'allemagne lorsque les forces alliées
libérer ceux qui avaient passé parfois
cinq ans derrière des barbelés
le 25 avril les deux pointes nord et sud
de l'attak soviétique pour faire tomber
berlin finir d'encercler la capitale
allemande
à moins de 160 km au sud-est ce même
jour eu lieu la première rencontre entre
les troupes américaines et l'armée rouge
dans son rapport le maréchal yvan konev
commandant du premier front ukrainien
indiqua que le premier contact eu lieu
vers 13h30 entre les troupes de la 58e
division de fusiliers de la garde et de
la 5ème armée de la garde avec un
détachement de reconnaissance de la 69e
division d'infanterie américaine ashtray
là
cette première rencontre fut suivie
d'une autre lorsqu'un capitaine du 163e
régiment des fusiliers de la garde
rencontre à une autre patrouille
américaine à torgau
cependant la rencontre officielle entre
les deux alliés s'est déroulé vers 16h40
quand une patrouille conduite par le
lieutenant william bill robinson de la
69e division d'infanterie rencontre à
plusieurs soldats soviétiques à torgau
événements dans les célébrations furent
filmés par des caméras man des deux
camps pour leur cinéma respectifs et qui
présentait un événement comme la
séparation de l'allemagne nazie en deux
parties
fraternisation qui suivit entre les deux
armées des deux grandes puissances fut
de courte durée
même si les sentiments exprimés par ceux
qui prirent part à l'événement était
sans aucun doute sincère
cet officier effectué une danse amical
avec un soldat de l'armée rouge tandis
que le personnel de l' us army profite
de cette soirée de printemps sous l'oeil
de joseph staline
un général américain eut l'opportunité
de jeter un coup d'oeil sur un char t34
de l'armée rouge
il n'y a pas de doute sur l'intérêt que
portait ce général à ce superbe chars
venir les lui donner raison
cinq ans plus tard les sherman allait
affronter ces machines soviétique dans
les collines de corée
le sixième groupe d'armées du général
diverses comprenant la 7e armée de
patcher la première armée française
avancée pour couvrir le flanc droit de
la troisième armée bien que les français
frustré motivés ils n'étaient pas
formidablement bien équipé et diverses
savait qu'il devrait leur apporter
assistance
la crainte d'une résistance allemande
dans les alpes l'incitent à orienter ses
forces vers le sud et la bavière afin
d'anéantir toute possibilité d'un
sursaut national le 12 avril
eisenhower et bradley détournèrent
l'armée de patton vers le sud pour
assister diverses les forces américaines
dans le sud de l'allemagne étaient
confrontés à une farouche résistance
à ce stade de la gare un grand nombre de
tanks sherman de l'us army avait été
équipé d'une protection improvisé pour
compenser de la vulnérabilité du
blindage pro fin du hem 4 face aux armes
allemandes à grande vélocité des cadres
soudé était attaché aux tourelles et à
la structure par des techniciens afin de
supporter des sacs de sable ce sharman
bulldozer portant des sacs de sable est
équipé du canon standard m3 de 75 mm
ce bricolage improvisé donnait un peu
plus d'assurance aux équipages mais son
efficacité n'était pas évidente
la ville de nuremberg intensément
bombardé fut finalement prise le 20
avril après de violents combats
deux divisions de l'armée allemande
assistés par des détachements de la fox
tourner de la luftwaffe et une petite
force de blindés ainsi qu'un grand
nombre de canons antichars répartis
autour de la ville offrait une forte
résistance
les canons de 88 et 105 mm furent
utilisés avec une grande efficacité
contre les blindages américain pendant
que deux divisions du 15e corps attaqué
la ville depuis le nord ouest
d'autres venus du 21e corps avançait
dans les faubourgs ouest tandis qu'un
important groupe mobile coupet toutes
les retraites possible au sud
les techniciens du génie effectué un
travail remarquable en construisant des
ponts provisoires sur les voies d'eau de
la ville pour remplacer ceux qui avaient
été détruits un camion 6 6 2 2 tonnes 5
précèdent un dodge transporteurs de
munitions sur un de ces ponts le plus
important des véhicules remorqueur
d'artillerie produits promus et sammy a
été le m5 tracteur rapide du ici
traversant un pont à nuremberg remords
quant à eux huit soeurs de 155 mm
obusiers lourd standard
il est suivi par un half track m16
équipé de quatre mitrailleuses de 12 7
mm utilisable pour la défense anti
aérienne pendant quelques heures à la
suite de la prise de nuremberg le 20
avril
les gi's prennent le temps de se reposer
dans le stade de la ville où hitler
tenait les grands meetings du parti nazi
dans les années 30
c'est à l'endroit où se trouvent sur ces
images les musiciens de jazz que le
führer s'adressait aux fidèles de son
parti et expliquer les objectifs de sa
politique qui allait entraîner le monde
entier dans la guerre en septembre 1939
sans aucun doute parmi ses soldats
certains devaient apprécier l'ironie que
leur présence symbolisait à savoir
l'occupation par l'us army du centre
spirituel du régime nazi et du troisième
reich qui devait durer mille ans et qui
était tombé au bout de 12 ans
l'allemagne étant désormais coupé en
deux la plupart des raids des
bombardiers lourds américains se
concentraient essentiellement contre le
sud du pays
en autriche et en tchécoslovaquie le 19
avril se déroule à la dernière rencontre
entre des b 17 et les chasseurs à
réaction allemand les bombardiers moyens
b26 maraudeur opérèrent également contre
des cibles dans cette région jusqu'à sa
reddition
ils purent témoigner que les daims de la
luftwaffe restait à céret même lors de
ses derniers combats du 20 au 26 avril
les b 26 des 17e 322e 323e et 334e
groupe de bombardement engagés dans des
combats subir des pertes conséquentes
paso messerschmidt 262 de la jv 44 qui
opérait depuis la base aérienne de
munich
[Musique]
sur ces images
un chasseur de chars légers et soeurs
qui traînent abandonné sur le bord de la
route probablement victimes d'un p 47 en
maraude et le vent passe une jeep et
half track m3 d'un détachement de
reconnaissance
opérant en avant d'une forces blindées
ces véhicules traversent un village qui
semble désert et tracent leur route vers
leur destination
un aérodrome abandonné
il passe devant les restes du fuselage
d'un juncker j eu 88 g chasseur de nuit
camouflé comme l'étaient ces appareils
sur de très nombreuses aérodrome un très
grand nombre d'avions de la luftwaffe
furent découverts abandonnée voici deux
des 20m 26 pershing qui sont entrés en
service en allemagne avant la fin de la
guerre les équipages de chars us ont
beaucoup apprécié le blindage lourd de
ce nouvel engin et le puissant canons de
90 mm qui pouvait rivaliser avec celui
du tigre affectés aux 3e et 9e division
blindée le pershing reçu son baptême du
feu de dix jours avant la prise du pont
de remagen des vingt exemplaires engagé
au combat un seul n'arriva pas à la fin
de la guerre
mis hors de combat par le canon de 88 mm
d'un chasseur de chars allemands dans
les combats autour de cologne
les chars manette est fréquemment
utilisé par l'us army comme martyr
immobile dans ce rôle d n 4 à 2 et d y
ait font donner leurs canons de 75 mm ou
de 76 mm long pour bombardé un village
dans lequel une unité allemande s'est
retranché il semble que c'était alors le
meilleur moyen de venir à bout de ces
poches de résistance tenue par les
soldats jusqu'au boutiste
ces chars affecté à la 11ème division
blindée faisant partie de la troisième
armée de patton traversant une rivière
en autriche le 4 mai pendant leur
avancée vers la cité de lindt permettent
d'observer comment était constitué une
telle formation dans les derniers jours
de la guerre
dm quatre à trois derniers modèles avec
la voix incliné à 47 degrés et armé d'un
canon de 75 mm sont utilisés par
l'infanterie pour traverser la rivière
très froides et très agitée en raison de
la fonte des neiges
le char suivant est à 1,26 pershing
également utilisé comme un transport de
troupe improvisée plus lourd que le
sherman des précautions sont prises pour
faciliter la montée du hem 26 sur la
rive afin d'empêcher qu'elle ne
s'effondre sous son poids un mur a été
démolie et les briques lancé dans la
boue pour que les chenilles des chars
puisse s'accrocher permettent au
véhicule d'avancé
dans cette séquence des m7 priest et dm4
traverse suivi par plusieurs camions de
deux tonnes et demie transportant le
matériel nécessaire à la progression qui
se poursuit dès la rivière franchi les
blindés fonce sur la route
sur ses prises de vue le m4 à trois
modèles de sherman le plus répandu dans
l' us army sont avant incliné à 47
degrés est ses filets de rangement
indique qu'il s'agit d'un mk a318 la
dernière version bénéficions d'une toute
nouvelle suspension et de nouvelles
chenilles ainsi que d'une tourelle
équipé d'un canon de 76 mm long il fut
largement utilisé bien après la guerre
la reddition final des forces allemandes
est proche
il est apparent que pour ses soldats en
captivité au début du mois de mai la
guerre est bel et bien terminée il
savait déjà qu hitler s'était suicidé
même si la radio mentait en annonçant
qu'il était mort aux côtés de ses
troupes en combattant les russes dans
berlin l'armée américaine éprouvé les
plus grandes difficultés à gérer cette
arrivée massive de prisonniers des
unités du génie étaient fréquemment
réquisitionnés pour construire des zones
de rétention provisoire pour les
prisonniers ennemis en attendant que des
installations permanentes soient
fabriqués au début du mois de mai de
nombreuses unités allemandes avaient
agité le drapeau blanc et se rendaient
en masse ils furent parqués dans des
champs ouverts à tous vents
dès le 1er mai la pointe de la troisième
armée de patton avaient franchi la
frontière autrichienne
la résistance ennemis fut rapidement
brisé et le maréchal kesselring battitte
en retraite vers berchtesgaden certaines
divisions s'emparèrent de brandão les
autres se dirigeait vers l'île où ils
entrèrent le 5 mai une fois de plus ce
sont les prisonniers qui illustre la
situation
la place centrale de la ville devient le
point de rassemblement d'allemands
vaincu arrivé à pied ou en camion
la grande diversité de couleur des
uniformes montre que ces soldats servait
dans l'armée de terre de la luftwaffe ou
dans les folles stumm
bien que les troupes américaines n'ai
rien à craindre les tanks et les half
track m3 sont organisés autour de la
place assurant une grande sécurité
pendant le travail de recensement et
d'orientation des prisonniers vers leur
lieu de détention
la plupart des sharman sondés m 4 à 3
l'équipe et du canon de 75 mm un certain
nombre de visites sont également
présents
à la différence d'autres villes
industrielles autrichienne linz ne
montre nulle trace de dommages de guerre
la ville ne possédant pas d'industrie
d'armement importante fut épargné par
les bombardements que les autres villes
avaient subi
line c'était la ville où hitler avait
déclaré vouloir se retirer après la
guerre pour se remettre à la peinture
son architecture l'avait toujours séduit
il avait de grands projets pour la
transformer selon ses propres idées et
ses propres goûts
pourtant leur bal
en tenant le peu qu'ils étaient
autorisés à conserver les prisonniers
allemands défilèrent sous bonne garde au
premier plan se trouve l'équipage d'un
half track m3 dont le mitrailleur est
assis sur l'arceau de sa mitrailleuse la
12,7 à portée de main
marchante à l'extérieur de la ville il
passe devant un autre sherman à 3 sa
couleur vert olive disparaît sous une
couche de poussière
après la capitulation allemande le 16
mai des processions entière de soldats
allemands se sont formés
linz marque le point le plus au sud
atteint par les hommes de patton alors
que d'autres troupes américaines se
trouvait plus proche des troupes
soviétiques
mais la plupart des unités allemandes se
sont présentés dalle même à lui été
remis afin d'échapper aux russes
les soldats américains récupèrent les
armes de poing des officiers allemands
tandis que quelques autres
une tente de fraterniser avec les
soldats américains une immense pile
d'équipement abandonnés se dresse sur le
côté de la route
on y trouve pêle mêle des fusils des
pistolets des étuis à masques à gaz des
casques et même un drapeau des éléments
de la troisième armée entre air temps
tchécoslovaquie le 6 mai patton était
prêt à y entrer depuis deux bonnes
semaines
by the way mais bradley était inquiet à
propos des russes qui s'ils battaient
encore plus tard quand on leur demanda
pourquoi sa troisième armée était si
désireuse de libérer la tchécoslovaquie
patton rétorqua pour la tchécoslovaquie
et pour la fraternisation
un accord avec les russes fut trouvée
pour permettre aux américains de
s'approcher de prague sur le point
d'être libérés par l'armée rouge
les tchécoslovaques les accueillir avec
enthousiasme tout au long des routes
vers pis nous
ici une colonne de chars légers m24 sa
fille entre dans pile sun acclamé par
ses habitants il sonne était sous la
coupe des allemands depuis 1938
cependant l'enthousiasmé de la foule
tchèque rassemblés pour cette libération
avait vite être refroidis par la dureté
de l'occupation soviétique
traversons il sonne comme captifs l'état
major et les troupes de la 7e armée
allemande avait été repoussée en
tchécoslovaquie par l' avance rapide de
la troisième armée en autriche
quelques semaines plus tôt
à l'instar de tous ceux qui étaient
désormais éparpillés en allemagne en
autriche et en tchécoslovaquie
cet immense dépôt de matériel militaire
allemand est composé de véhicules légers
dont quelques modèles identifiable de
half track sdk et faisait 251
la plupart des camions sont des modèles
opel mercedes ou tatra
la plupart sur des véhicules de
transport mais il ya aussi un certain
nombre de versions spéciales
une rareté au milieu de toutes ces
épaves c3 puma véhicules blindés à huit
roues dont seulement quelques
exemplaires ont été construits en 1944
la principale difficulté à laquelle fut
confronté l'armée américaine dans les
heures qui suivirent la réduction du 7 m
puis le faire face à l'afflux en
constante augmentation de prisonniers
sur toutes les routes du sud de
l'allemagne et des zones occupées de
tchécoslovaquie de longues colonnes de
prisonniers rejoignait les zones
d'internement provisoire et les camps
les infrastructures allemande étant
détruites les alliés devaient assumer la
responsabilité non seulement des
approvisionnements pour la population
civile mais aussi pour les militaires
qui se rendaient par centaines de
milliers
sans surprise ces problèmes allaient
pousser la logistique alliée à ses
limites
l'armée américaine étaient bien
organisés et équipés pour faire face
même si cette situation posait de
sérieux problèmes
une des premières tâches fut de déplacer
le plus grand nombre possible de soldats
allemands des camps de rétention
temporaire proches de zones occupées par
l'armée rouge jusqu'au camp installés
dans les zones administrées par l' us
army en allemagne
en autriche et en tchécoslovaquie la
volonté de nombreuses unités allemandes
d'échapper à la captivité chez les
soviétiques cause à de sérieux problèmes
certaines unités avait plus que d'autres
de bonnes raisons de ne pas tomber entre
les mains des russes en particulier les
unités ss et toutes celles qui avaient
combattu essentiellement sur le front
russe
elle était réclamée par les soviétiques
qui les considéraient comme leur
prisonnier de plein droit
un bon exemple fut celui de est riche
hartmann le plus grand casse de la
guerre et de tous les temps avec 352
avion abattu à son actif tous russes
le 8 mai hartmann et bien d'autres
membres de la jg 52 s'était rendu à la
90e division d'infanterie américaine en
tchécoslovaquie
huit jours plus tard lui et ses
camarades les femmes et les enfants qui
les accompagnaient furent confiés aux
russes hartmann passa les dix années
suivantes prisonniers en russie
ces mouvements de prisonniers de guerre
se sont répétées régulièrement dans tous
les secteurs britanniques français et
américains en allemagne
en allemagne de l'est les gars se
remplissaient de prisonniers dès que des
trains était disponible pour les
transporter vers la russie
un grand nombre d'entre eux envoyé à
l'est furent déportés au goulag
ceux qui survécurent ne retournais en
allemagne qu'à partir de 1950
une des raisons de ces transports de
prisonniers était le besoin de les
regrouper pour que les autorités alliées
puisse commencer le processus d'examen
de longues listes avaient été préparées
avec les noms des membres du parti nazi
dss et de la wehrmacht que les alliés
recherchait
qu'ils avaient des qualités ou des
connaissances spéciales étaient sortis
des camps de prisonniers
gunther râle un autre à ce qu'ils
avaient deux cent soixante quinze
victoires à son actif raconta après la
guerre comment il s'était échappé d'un
immense camp à ciel ouvert près de
heidelberg
le commandant du camp arrive à un matin
avec une liste de noms dont le sien il
pensa que seuls les pilotes les plus
décorés étaient concernés mais il
découvrit plus tard que les autorités
américaines désiré garder tous les
pilotes qui avaient une expérience à
bord des chasseurs à réaction
messerschmidt 262
on lui demanda s'il voulait aller en
amérique ce qu'il accepta
plus tard il devint le commandant en
chef de la nouvelle luftwaffe d'après
guerre
d'autres spécialistes furent thaci
exfiltré de la sorte dont ceux qui
avaient travaillé sur les projets de
pointe comme les fusées v1 et v2
leurs talents et leurs connaissances au
delà de la défaite avait une certaine
valeur pour les vainqueurs
quelques jours seulement après la fin de
la guerre la belle alliance est ouest
commencé à se fissurer
le sort de la majorité des prisonniers
de guerre dans l'immédiat après-guerre
n'avait rien d'agréable
la plupart se trouvaient rassemblées
dans d'immenses zones à ciel ouvert
n'est pourvu d'installation
la nuit ils dorment à la belle étoile et
certains succombèrent de fatigue ou de
maladie
il était très difficile de s'occuper de
temps de prisonniers à la fois
il est également juste de reconnaître
qu'à la lumière des découvertes du côté
sombre de l'allemagne nazie nombreux
étaient ceux qui du côté des alliés ne
voyaient dans cette situation qu une
juste punition pour les crimes commis
la prise de salzburg et de berchtesgaden
par le 15e corps américain mis un terme
à la possibilité d'un sursaut allemand
dans les alpes
berchtesgaden avait été épargnée des
ravages de la guerre est resté conforme
à l'image des cartes postales d'avant
guerre cependant la proximité de la
retraite montagnards de d'hitler le
célèbre nid d'aigle le berghof ainsi que
la vallée autour de la ville résonnait
du bruit des bombes
quelques jours avant l'arrivée des
troupes américaines
le 26 avril le bon beurre commandes de
la rfl ans à un raid deux jours avec des
bombardiers lourds lancaster
directement contre le site
ce fut le dernier raid majeur de la
guerre en épi des tirs des batteries qui
défendent est le nid d'aigle les
dommages subis furent importants comme
le montre ce film tourné par les soldats
américains en train d'explorer les
ruines
le bombardement avait été concentrés sur
les installations des ss le nid d'aigle
et le chalet dit claire bien connu pour
avoir été présenté dans beaucoup de
documents lorsqu'ils cléry accueillait
personnellement de nombreux dignitaires
étrangers avant et pendant la guerre
des films le montre et se reposant
entouré d'un certain nombre de grandes
figures du régime comme green boorman
goebel himmler et spir
bien sûr certains disposaient de leur
propre chalet à proximité goering avait
quitté berlin pour son chalet proche de
salzbourg dans les jours qui précédèrent
la chute de berlin et la reddition
finale de l'allemagne
hitler était particulièrement fier de la
très grande baie vitrée et de la vue
qu'on y avait des montagnes aux
alentours
il fut souvent photographiés dans cette
pièce
les soldats américains profite ici de ce
qui reste de cette pièce où l'histoire
s'est écrite et se penche par le trou se
trouvait la grande fenêtre ni truite le
26 avril
plus tard le bergot fut démolie il ne
reste pratiquement plus rien aujourd'hui
bien qu'ayant joué un rôle secondaire à
la fin du troisième reich le maréchal
hermann goering restait le leader nazi
le plus connu après hitler
goering pensait que eisenhower désire s
entretenir avec lui mais il dut vite
abandonné cette idée
son principal sujet d'inquiétude était
hitler qui l'avait renier et avait
désigné l'amiral de nietzsche comme son
successeur
lorsque le 20 mai il s'envola pour le
luxembourg il se retrouva avec d'autres
grands dignitaires du reich un rapport
confidentiel envoyé par un de ses
interrogateurs signalait que goering ne
devait pas être sous-estimé est
considéré comme un personnage
sympathique comme son allure et ses
manières pouvait le laisser croire
mais qu'en réalité celle-ci cacher un
esprit froid et calculateur
ce qui éclata au grand jour lors du
procès de nuremberg où il s'affirma
comme un très habile contradicteurs
pendant la guerre en dehors de romell
peu de généraux allemands étaient connus
du public américain et britannique
1 2 et elle fait le martian von
rundstedt généralement décrit comme
l'archétype de l'officier prussien dans
l'armée allemande dont il fut un des
officiers majeur
il n'avait aucune sympathie pour les
nazis et n'avaient guère de
considération pour hitler qu'il
surnommait le caporal bohémiens en
présence de ses proches
régulièrement récuser ou sac et par
hitler en 1945 il était vieux et épuisé
il fut capturé le 2 mai on voit ici en
train de partir en captivité en 1945 il
fut condamné pour crimes de guerre par
un tribunal militaire britannique
mais fut libéré en 1949 il mourut en
le maréchal albert kesselring fut un
temps chef d'état-major de la luftwaffe
qu'il avait contribué à créer
il commanda en pologne en france en
russie en sicile et en italie du nord en
février 1945 il remplaça fans ronstadt
comme commandant du front ouest sans
pouvoir empêcher l'invasion alliée en
allemagne
il fut capturé à berchtesgaden le 15 mai
condamné à mort puis gracié
lorsqu'il fut nommé général inspecteur
de la chasse en décembre 1941
adolphe gallen était déjà un as de la
chasse réputé avec 94 victoire
officielle
débarqué de son poste en décembre 1944
sans cérémonie sac et par goering
il avait tenté d'organiser et
d'améliorer l'utilisation des chasseurs
de la luftwaffe
gallant devint le bouc émissaire de
göring qui lui reprochaient l'incapacité
de ses escadrilles à stopper la campagne
de bombardements alliés sur l'allemagne
portant son uniforme de lieutenant
général
arborant la croix avec épée et diamants
il est ici avec son interrogateur le
majeur max rosendor mme de l'ua sert
force
dans la meilleure tradition des pilotes
de chasse du monde entier il mime avec
leurs mains les évolutions de leurs
avions
cette conversation concerne le message
schmitt 262 et l'unité d'élite
la jv 44 que galante commanda de janvier
à la fin du conflit
hans ulrich roudel tomba entre les mains
américaines en dépit de la volonté les
russes de s'en emparer
car il n'avait été les principales
victimes de sa très grande habileté
ces statistiques sont uniques il fut le
soldat le plus décoré de tous les hommes
de l'armée allemande et l'aviateur le
plus décoré de tous les temps
c'est aux commandes de son juncker 87 ch
tout cas qu il bâti sa légende sur le
front russe
à la fin de la guerre il avait effectué
plus de 2000 mission et avait détruit
plus de 500 chars soviétiques avec les
canons de son jus 87 g
il continue à voler en dépit de la perte
de sa jambe droite au début 45
il fut le seul récipiendaire de la croix
de chevalier avec feuilles de chêne en
or et diamants
il est ici le 14 mai avec galande et
d'autres responsables de haut rang de
l'aviation et de l'armée avant
d'embarquer à bord d'un c 47 de
l'aviation américaine qui va les emmener
en angleterre pour des interrogatoires
et des les briefings approfondie
elle refusa de renoncer à sa sympathie
pour le régime nazi est cependant après
la guerre il joue un rôle politique en
allemagne de l'ouest
il est mort en 1982
dans les semaines qui suivirent la chute
de l'allemagne une équipe de cinéma
américaines responsables de ce film se
rendit à berlin pour fixer sur la
pellicule la cérémonie britannique
organisée en l'honneur du maréchal
djardji juke off pour son importante
contribution à la défaite de l'allemagne
les taux britanniques sont alignés en
ordre de parade et attendre l'arrivée de
l'officier qui doit les passer en revue
le maréchal montgomery arrive à bord de
son véhicule de commandement pour
effectuer la présentation au commandant
suprême soviétique juste devant les
colonnes constellée d'impacts de la
porte de brandebourg
ils ne s'étaient jamais rencontrés
jusqu'à lors tous deux avaient joué un
rôle équivalent au sein des nations
alliées juke of était aussi le
représentant soviétique au conseil des
alliés en allemagne
après son inspection de la guerre de
donneurs britannique
jack of passe en revue ligne de chars
britannique cromwell spécialement pas en
vert bronze
il ne fait aucun doute que c'est un
spécialiste qu'il jette un oeil sur le
matériel anglais
montgomery alva juke of au rang de grand
croix de chevalier de l'ordre du bain
une récompense symbolisée par l'écharpé
rouge que porte celui ci alors qu'il
regarde le dernier hommage de son
homologue britannique
entre les piliers centraux de la porte
de brandebourg
on peut voir un immense portrait de
joseph staline
il est placé là pour indiquer clairement
que c'est à cet endroit que la zone
soviétique de l'ancienne allemagne nazie
commence
la porte elle même a été le théâtre de
violents combats dans les derniers jours
de la bataille de berlin
tout comme le bâtiment du reichstag
un canon de 88 détruit symbolise la
bataille perdue pour la capitale
allemande
le bâtiment du reichstag l'objectif
prioritaire des soviétiques pendant les
derniers jours de la bataille de berlin
était devenu le dernier point de
résistance de la ville
l'assaut contre le bâtiment commencent à
le 30 avril par un bombardement
d'artillerie et de salves de roquettes
price tag fut ensuite attaqué par les
380e 560 14e et 750 6e régiment
d'infanterie plus de 5000 ss jeunesses
hitlériennes et folk stumm tentèrent de
repousser les assaillants
il fallu deux jours pour nettoyer le
reichstag avant que le drapeau rouge ne
soit hissé au dessus du bâtiment comme
symbole du triomphe de l'union
soviétique
achevez seulement en 1939
sans sellerie avait été conçue et
construite pour hitler par son
architecte albert spm devenu plus tard
ministre de la production de guerre
également en ruines
il avait été le théâtre de violents
combats
le bâtiment avait été imaginé par ses
pairs pour être la première étape dans
la reconstruction du centre de la ville
qui devait être la capitale du reich
destinée à durer mille ans et kit l'air
voulait étendre de l'atlantique à
l'oural
sur ce qui avait été la splendide corfou
steendam la grande avenue de la capitale
conduisant à la porte de brandebourg
l'église du grand kaiser guillaume était
en ruines comme pratiquement tous berlin
la caméra en passant film les façades
des immeubles détruits
il est encore possible de lire les noms
des hôtels des magasins de luxe des
théâtres qui avait rendu ce lieu célèbre
dès les premières semaines de paix la
population berlinoise a commencé à
déblayer les ruines
c'est ainsi que la reconstruction de la
ville a commencé
il faut remarquer que ceux qui effectue
ce travail sont essentiellement des
femmes et des enfants
la plupart des hommes sont prisonniers
morts dieu ou infirmes et l'on rencontre
très peu de jeunes hommes allemand dans
les rues de berlin en juillet 1945
un survol de l'ancienne capitale de
l'allemagne nazie témoignent des
terribles destructions causées par les
bombardements aériens de la rff la nuit
de la 8ème air force le jour et par les
combats menés par les russes pour
l'assaut final
très peu d'immeubles semble être encore
habitable la plupart n'étant plus que
des ruines
il fut vite évident que berlin allait
devenir un ange dans l'antagonisme qui
se développèrent la russie et ses
nouveaux alliés
les etats-unis la grande-bretagne et la
france dans un sens hitler a été
l'architecte de la grande alliance qui a
conduit ces puissances à se rassembler
et à l'amener à sa propre défaite mais
une fois le dictateur allemand sorti de
scène les vieilles rivalités
idéologiques les peurs et les suspicions
réapparurent sans tarder
il est tout à fait symbolique que la
dernière image soit celle de la porte de
brandebourg à la fois symbole de la
défaite de l'allemagne
elle devint pour les 50 années qui
suivirent le symbole du rideau de fer
qui sépare à l'europe au cours d'une
nouvelle guerre
heureusement rester froide